this capsule was worth translating the
Bezian network concept and we are going
to address the role that rose to the needs
can play in intelligence
artificial
so in this capsule and those who
will follow the goals are from
cover what is the definition of a
Bezian network is among others addressed the
concept of the structure of a network
bezels of probabilities in a network
beziers to see also commented this
we can identify independence
conditional from a
representation in network form
beziers of an environment on the other hand
how to make inference in a
Bezian network of inference is exact
or approximate and finally we will
see what we can build
automatic Bézian networks
with automatic learning
so we saw in the capsules
previous the basics of reasoning
probabilistic based on the theory of
probabilities
we have seen that if we define ourselves as a model
which actually corresponds to a table of
productive joint so we do not live a
previous southern cape where we had a table
then in our table we had several
random variables is the last
colony if we had the probabilities
associated with all assignments
possible of my random variable
so we saw because defining a model
so finally this table represents
finally a modeling of
relationships of the different concepts the
different elements of my environment
from models in this form
we were able to calculate several
probability of marginal qualities and
conditionalities that are useful for
make probabilistic reasoning that
will take into account our uncertainties by
relationship to these elements
there in our environment
we made a very simple example where we
had then you want to do the
detection emails from is this
that an email conceives that we hold good
meaning and where is it
the sender's address is unknown
in practice actually to get some
systems in over detection of spam
who works well who are who are
effective than a good one good
prediction performance we finally go
want to have hundreds or even
thousands of random Arabs makes that the
market approach based on a table like
this one will just not passable on
said random variable which are
binary bath then if one has ten thousand
variable it means we will have a
table with 2 to the 1000 ranger for the
2000 different configurations of our
random variable
are we going to see in the capsules
that will follow is that the networks
beziers will just allow us to
represent more effectively this
probability table there so
implicit
so that will allow us to build
a model for reasoning
project list but that is going to be a lot
more efficient in memory that will us
to be much more effective
also in our probability calculations
conditional is marginal then the
Bezier networks it is we can see that
as a kind of marriage between the
graph theory and theory of
probabilities the Bezier networks actually
will allow us to represent well
our probabilistic knowledge for a
given application so if we have
different clinical knowledge of a
expert corresponds to a doctor in this
case also which represents links of
causality between diseases of
symptoms the Hobbesian are going to us
allow to represent that way
still quite intuitive actually placed
directly the Bezier networks go
take care of it to model site of
knowledge there that can be
used in for example a kind of
expert system that
a system that will support the taking of
decisions by one person and this
particle is particularly useful
when one is in a situation where the
causality plays an important role so we
is able to identify events
so random variables that cause
who have a causal relationship with
other random in my
environment
and it's especially useful when
these causal relationships there are not
fully understood so we do not have in
makes causal relationships that are
deterministic and we want to incorporate a
other notion of relative certainties
what are its causal relationships
who is able to handle this
uncertainty there to make our
probabilistic reasoning let's see
some examples of applications then
promised is when I mentioned earlier
medical diagnosis or another
network beziers will allow us to
enter others model the relationship
between the possible disease of building
patients and its symptoms associated with
disease and with two Bezier networks
among other things what will be useful is
that we are going to be able to lighthouse the
probabilistic reasoning among others
when we do not really know
the set of symptoms so where the
set of information the social and
environment so that's okay that would
easy for us to identify what is
age sex is there no one
not smoke if he has information that
are easy to acquire however
identify if you finally die in
in the patient or also do a test
who measures calcium levels his cdc
operations it's information that
is expensive to acquire that we do not have
necessarily access which one is painted
aksil oath in any situation and
so his coming with the obediences is in
measure actually first two to model
the causal relationships between these
different aspects there of our situation
then be able then to care of
do different in this case also this
which really interests us to know
does our patient have cancer or
not by the way there are systems of
medical diagnosis that have been
developed 1 which is particularly
impressive is that of the pathfinder
which is based on bezier networks he
was developed at an extracting the
expertise of different systems but in
modeling this expertise there in a
network well we see here this is the
bezian network what if he is very very
big of each peelings like that
is actually a league from everything
our network bezy so this very big
bezier network and the results that have
been obtained are still enough
impressive
if we compare is the kind of diagnosis
made by this system there to experts 20
50 times out of 53 we got there was
agreement between the automated system and
the experts and the predictions were
considered to be equally good too
valid than that of the experts who were
solicited to develop the system
so the expertise of the doctors that you
want doctors whose appraised has been
embedded in the beziers network he
made predictions that is also
good that the automated system
we can also diagnose but
in this case computer
there are microsoft tools like by
example the famous clip i software
word that uses the associated technology
to benzian networks or do
identification of two problems by
example related to printing and 8 in
windows so these are
these are applications that use
Bezier networks that has been developed
and used a lot by people from
microsoft non application this is the
prediction of road traffic
again we are going to be a
application named djembe type of
technology that makes it possible to do the
prediction of what would be the traffic
road from information
partial like road reports
or weather information is located
and it's an application done that they
could work on a device
mobile like a cell phone
our application list here so the
nasa to do sports diagnosis in
real-time system failures
propulsion of a space vacuum
at & t use it the bézy networks
redo the detection of fraud or
detecting bad payers for
telephone bills classification of
obese documents will go very very
still used today to make the
classification of documents is
often one of the approaches
declassification of documents which is
relatively old but works
particularly well and in too much of the
spam detection there are many who
is made from networks of beziers
which will allow us in too many
support for only two variables
random diagnosis as it is
done in an example really support
several other variables and also the
bezy networks are behind kind of
technology to do the localization
robots in a map so let's imagine
that we have robots walking around in a
effective environment and identify
where they are on a map of this
environment there the Bezier networks
can be used to try
to attack this problem